[Musique]
c'est
quelque chose qui se vend très facilement sur le
marché noir
et les agriculteurs subissent de très grosses
pertes
avec les vols dans leurs fermes.
[Musique] [
Musique]
ok,
dans le passé, c'était généralement
une situation où les gens
venaient  en volant les fruits et en les vendant
au bord de la route,
de nos jours, ils sont lavés, emballés
dans des boîtes appropriées, expédiés
avec un transport approprié vers
des marchés appropriés et des marchés organisés, même
[Musique]
si cette pénalité peut être
dure pour les gens qui prennent les choses
[Musique]
euh sans condition  c'est alors que nous serons en sécurité,
mais tant que la pénalité est
légère,
tout le monde viendra vers vous et fera
ce que vous voulez
pour que cela vienne du gouvernement,
plus nous avons besoin de fruits à emballer, plus
nous avons besoin de capacité chez les emballeurs.  plus
nous devons employer de personnes,
car des risques tels que le vol d'avocats
affectent directement ces personnes en termes d'
emploi.